大約2000年前
醫聖張仲景
只看一個時間點
就能夠開藥
治肝病腹水腫
真的假的
用時間就可以治病喔
真的喔 我告訴你真的
治肝病還要
選在什麼時候
你知道嗎
春季的早上
這個時候
是肝氣最旺的時候
治肝的效果最好
人的體質和時間
是有密切關係的
今天呢
我就來告訴你
這個體質密碼
是怎麼計算出來的
胡乃文開講囉
我是你的老朋友 胡醫師
這一集要和你分享
1.教你1招看5大體質 你是哪一種
2.5種體質對症吃 改善老毛病
孫女一問 阿公解答真相太爆笑
教你1招看體質 你是哪一種
如何判斷
你是哪一種體質
從你出生的那一刻開始
嘿 你就有一組體質密碼
我們可以用
古人研究出來的
所謂的天干地支
這一個時間系統
和五行來配對
就能夠
算出來
你是哪一種體質
怎麼樣
來調養身體才最健康
聽起來很複雜耶
你可以教我們
簡單一點的嗎
沒問題
我現在就分享
一個簡單的方法給你
你能知道自己的體質
連你小孩
是哪一種體質
你都可以知道
這個方法就是
看你是哪一個季節出生的
你現在注意聽喔
一共有五種體質
木火土金水
對應
春夏秋冬
這個方法就是
你是出生於哪個月的
而那個月
剛好是
春季的
就叫做木行人
是夏季 就叫火行人
是秋季 就叫金行人
是冬季 就叫做水行人
另外在中間還有
辰戌丑未幾個月出生的
那個就叫做土行人
用出生的季節來判斷體質
是簡單又實用的
一種分類方法
想要更準的話呢
那我們就得
要用八字日主天干了
那是更進階的版本了
這集先學會這一招
就已經很好用了啦
金行人體質
吃1色食物養肺潤燥
如果是金行人的體質
要注意哪些健康問題呢
你是不是
一吹冷氣就咳嗽
一換季節
就鼻子哈啾哈啾
是不是
這就是典型的金行人體質
這種體質的人容易
鼻子過敏
咳嗽
便秘
因為肺和大腸
都比較
跟別人不一樣
你可以吃什麼來補一補
雪梨
山藥
白木耳等等
白色食物吃起來
補肺又潤燥
請注意一點哦
夏天的時候
不要整天
就是吹著冷氣
就是狂喝冷飲
太多寒涼之氣上身
你就容易咳嗽了
真的耶
我的朋友就是金行人
早上起來
就一直流鼻水
打噴嚏
然後衛生紙
就像在包水餃
包的很多捏
就像你說的這樣
可能哦
這種就可能是
所謂的金行人
木行人體質
常梳頭
常梳頭 吃2菜疏肝解鬱
第二種體質
叫做木行人
這種人
常常有
創意的點子
是不是最近
情緒也比較悶悶啊
眼睛乾睡不好
木型人的體質就要注意
就是他的肝火
會比較來得旺一點
眼睛乾澀心情鬱悶
還常常
一肚子的
怒火
給你一套
木行人養生的組合
疏肝解鬱
多吃
菠菜
芹菜
這些綠色的食物
搭配梳頭30下
在睡前拍肝經
肝經怎麼拍呢
手用空心掌
從大腿內側
拍到小腿的內側
現在拍肝經
先從左邊開始
我們拍幾次
拍三次好了
從上面開始往下拍
再拍右邊
一樣手是抱空的
一邊拍一邊還要吐氣
這樣子就可以疏肝理氣
緩解肝鬱氣滯
為什麼睡前拍最好呢
肝經的運行時間就是
晚上1點到3點
那你在11點到1點
這是子時
那是走膽經
肝膽是同一致
這個時間來拍一拍
氣一順了呢
火氣就降下來了
不但是睡得好
氣色也好
整個人也不容易悶住
老生悶氣了
水行人的體質
一累就腰痠背痛
要吃溫補食物
第三種水行人體質呢
你在冬天出生
天寒地凍的
寒氣特別重
是不是比較容易
手腳冰冷
腰痠背痛
多做一點事就感到
哇 很疲累
疲勞的不得了
常常半夜起來尿尿啊
有多尿和夜尿的問題
睡不好覺
你給我注意一點
就是讓人自己保暖起來
喝黑豆水
泡腳
雙管齊下
吃一些溫補的食物
黑芝麻
枸杞
核桃
這樣做都能固腎養腎
我再講最重要的一件事
就是不要熬夜
很多人問
腎虛怎麼辦
答案就是
先把睡眠補好
熬夜你的腎就虛
腎一虛
整個人就都虛掉了
火行人嘴破失眠
靠3個法寶來護心調回來
第四種體質
叫做火行人
夏天出生的你啊
是不是熱情如火
嘿 嗓門又大
朋友常說
你人没到 聲音就到啊
要注意的就是
注意火氣太旺會燒過頭哦
你有這種情況嗎
嘴巴破 口乾 舌燥
失眠
還有
咽喉好像總是被掐住
呼吸不順
心悸都上身
怎麼辦呢
教你護心三法寶
一 喝一碗蓮子湯
降火氣又護心
這個蓮子哦
可以帶著那個蓮子心更好哦
蓮子本來是要把心去掉的
二 深呼吸
讓自己心神安定下來
三 打坐
五到十分鐘
靜心就不急躁了
土行人 山藥薏仁小米
吃好吃滿
第五種體質土行人
你天生就有一種穩重感
人緣好
是職場和
朋友圈的人氣王
你的健康問題
常常就是
脾胃虛弱
容易脹氣
容易濕氣重
我推薦給你三個好食物
山藥
薏仁
小米
常吃能夠
健脾養胃
提醒你一件事
冰品冷飲呢
就少喝
才能把脾胃
養得健健康康的
古人的學問
怎麼那麼深奧啊
我很好奇耶
他們沒有網路啊
怎麼會知道
這麼多東西
嘿
你以為古人沒有網路
沒有AI
他就不懂養生嗎
錯
他們靠的是比人工智慧
更要厲害的
大腦訓練模組
他們呢日觀人相
夜觀天象
抬頭看星辰
低頭是看草木
整個大自然
就是他們的資料庫
一花一世界
一葉一乾坤
他們從四季的冷熱
動植物的變化中
就理出來一套時間的密碼
叫做天干地支
這是一套結合天文
氣候
跟生理的時間醫學
有三大好處
可以看運勢
可以看體質來斷健康
過好生活
在我的臨床經驗上呢
我也會運用天干地支
這一套時間醫學
治療不同的疑難雜症
它是一套
流傳千年的完整領域
到底天干地支是啥
有多厲害
馬上來告訴你
我先講天干
天干就是
甲乙丙丁戊己
庚辛壬癸十個
再來講地支
地支就是
子丑寅卯辰巳
午未申酉戌亥
這十二個
每一個地支
對應一個生肖
子丑寅卯辰巳
午未申酉戌亥
對應了
鼠牛虎兔龍蛇
馬羊猴雞狗豬
你可以講台語嗎
我真的
考倒我了
試試看
鼠牛虎兔龍蛇馬羊猴雞狗豬
很棒啊
重點來了
你的天干對應你的五行屬性
如何算你自己的天干呢
從你出生的年份
就可以看出來了
甲乙屬木要顧肝
丙丁屬火要養心
戊己屬土要養脾胃
庚辛屬金要護肺
壬癸屬水要補腎
我舉個例子
像是小編
他說他是1993年出生的
1993年他的天干就是癸
於是就說他是水行人
要補腎顧骨本
孫女一問
阿公解答真相太爆笑
上次
孫女問我一個問題
我差點回答不出來
她怎麼說
她說阿嬤
那貓
貓咪很可愛
她說牠在十二生肖裡
牠怎麼沒排到
孫女
阿公知道啦
這個故事
背後有一段爆笑又帶點
有點心機的結局
很久很久以前
人類還不會
算年份的時候
就去求玉皇大帝幫幫忙
玉皇大帝說好啊
那我就選十二個動物
來當生肖好不好
誰先跑到我這裡
就能當上
動物界的守護神
這場生肖大賽
貓跟老鼠
牠們都報名了
可是牠們兩個
都是不會游泳的
就靈機一動
兩個傢伙
就跳到牛的背上
然後搭順風車過河
眼看就快到終點了
誰知道老鼠竟然的
把貓推下水去
自己一溜煙
就跑上岸了
搶了個第一名
結果牛成了第二名
所以你看我們
這個十二生肖的
次序
鼠牛虎兔是老鼠帶第一個
牛屬第二個
然後再其他的
可憐的貓
拼了命游上岸才發現
哇 十二個的名額早就滿了
貓就氣得跳腳
老鼠你這個心機鬼
竟然來捉弄我
就是這樣
才有人說
才有人說報老鼠冤
貓看到老鼠
牠就會想要抓牠
對 原來是這樣
以後看到貓追老鼠
很可能就是
當年十二生肖的
世紀大恩怨續集
演到現在還沒演完呢
阿孫
阿公有沒有幫你解開謎啦
親愛的粉絲們
我們已經開啟會員頻道了
如果你認同胡醫師推廣中醫
照顧自己健康的理念
歡迎每月小額支持
或成為VIP贊助者
有你同行
我們才能走得更遠
真心感謝你哦